joe biden a annoncé que la lutte contre
locaux vides serait une de ses priorités
de même que les défaillances dans ce
domaine était un des sujets qu'il
critiquait le plus chez son prédécesseur
le président n'a pas de plan il n'a rien
préparé
il savait déjà en février à quel point
la crise était grave
il dit qu'il faut reprendre le travail
et s'est débarrassé du coït
on ne peut pas relancer le pays sans
avoir d'abord maîtriser locaux vides le
président des etats-unis a été testé
positif aux convives
ce n'est pas de la politique c'est un
rappel fort qu'il faut prendre ce virus
au sérieux je baille donne dit qu'il a
un plan de 200 pages
mais la longueur et l'éloquence d'un
document ne garantissent pas son succès
je baille donne commence à peine et déjà
20 millions de doses de vaccins ont
disparu ce mystère pour ainsi dire
aubert les capacités de vaccination
rapide du gouvernement
cela fait une semaine et l'équipe byden
cherche toujours les doses manquant dans
le même temps certaines des communautés
les plus touchées par le caue vides font
face à de graves difficultés dans la
vaccination à los angeles une foule de
manifestants anti vaccins ont bloqué
l'accès aux dogues stadium et empêcher
des gens de recevoir le vaccin
les opérations ont été interrompues
pendant plus d'une heure incroyable si
vous refusez les accents très bien mais
des millions d'angelin le veulent seize
mille de vos voisins sont morts donc
dégager le chemin des manifestants ne
sont pas le seul problème
new york est en état d'urgence tempête
de neige et les vaccinations se sont
interrompus là bas aussi
tout comme dans l'orégon pour des
raisons météorologiques également faute
de transport certaines personnes n'ont
pas pu revenir recevoir leur seconde
dose à temps
les docteurs ont dû commencer à
distribuer les vaccins
qu'ils pouvaient sont fragiles un
problème de réfrigération peu gâché tout
un lot de 100 à seattle les docteurs ont
vacciné aussi rapidement que possible
après une panne de réfrigérateur lorsque
c'est arrivé
la réaction immédiate a été nous devons
injecter ces 1600 doses dans les 12
prochaines heures au travail et à 3h15
du matin
nous y étions arrivés environ la moitié
des américains sont prêts à se faire
vacciner malgré le chaos
mais parmi les populations déjà septique
les inquiétudes sont fortes
la défiance le rejet de la vaccination
sera un des obstacles majeurs à
l'objectif de joe biden de sortir
rapidement le pays de la crise
pour le moment la planification apparaît
difficile joe biden ne semble pas avoir
de programme clair mais l'équipe de la
maison blanche qui n'a de cesse
d'alléguer de ces bonnes intentions
personne n'avait que les éléments les
plans en cours à l'époque reposer sur la
supposition que des informations
supplémentaires seraient disponibles
révélé une fois à la maison natale
légende de la boxe américaine a dit un
jour que tout le monde a un plan jusqu'à
ce qu'on se prenne un coup de poing dans
les dents et semble assez clair à ce
stade que les états unis n'étaient pas
préparés pour le crochet du droit
infligée par la pandémie
le temps presse
les gens meurent et le vaccin tant
désiré reste nimbée de chaos et de
confusion tiers